Kristen and Steve are you guys ready for
a game of rapid fire with four Fandango
yes sure I don't know what I'm getting
into
okay let's do it having an army of
minions yay or nay yay which minion is
your favorite in the DM 3 Mel Jerry or
Dave Dave Dave Dave is that one yep yep
he's the yellow one favorite 80s
hairstyle flock of seagulls or the Bon
Jovi doesn't the flock of seagulls kind
of like come up and the Bon Jovi's more
like a feathered back softer it's much
softer well if it's softer I'll go with
that go better softer because I want
something does it frame your face yes
yeah that's the one I get I want a frame
I was always saying that more frequent
face very careful approve banana clip
banana Club did not understand what you
just said I want to bring back the back
the banana clip what is the other one a
hair clip would that frame my face not
so much not as much I'm gonna go closely
okay what would your super villain name
be evil Steve
dr. W like it that's so scary
yeah you're most despicable trait my
most despicable trait would be the fact
that I always want to frame my face I
can't get away
Kristen is like the nicest person you
can't answer that I sometimes I'm not
great with dishes in the morning
what good is not Despicable um oh I hit
people with my car on the weekends your
most minion esque trait I talk fast
night a little and I am jaundice Steve
Carell Kristen Wiig you guys go check
out Despicable Me 3 in theaters you want
to tease let's tease it yeah come on
come see the movie you should you see it
I don't know you don't want to see you
want to see it do you want this oh do
you that's our tease you were better
yeah bat thank you
[Laughter]
you